haha the Joe Rogan experience whatever a
comedian tells you how dangerous and
they are like haha
oh she's like he's not he's not edge of
your date like you shouldn't write hate
that he's gonna have nonsense he's gonna
say nonsense I've already heard before
yeah like Dave Attell never tells the
audience hang on which makes them end
times edgy ER that might be the lamest
thing comedians do is tell you they're
edgy I see that all the time this there
was a guy who would go on stage he would
sit backwards in the chair he would go
welcome to the inside of my mom know
that man need some mushrooms oh so bad
you need to just wake up after it's over
go oh my god I gotta change everything
hey Who am I I'm so glad for all the LSD
trips I took back in the 90s because
they you come out of it and just gotta
go
oh yeah okay maybe I need to like just
anything just shrink yourself in the
universe yeah and make you more secure
with like oh this is actually vast and
I'm tiny in it knowing how tiny you are
actually gives you more strength and
freedom because you're like if
everything I do is insignificant then I
can do anything like if it's ultimately
all crumble so just do whatever you want
well sometimes when I get really high
and I feel real vulnerable I feel like
there's almost like there's magic in the
world whereas like when I'm sober
everything seems sort of it's like
standard everything's just as it always
is I'm accustomed to all these paths and
I'm accustomed to getting in my car and
driving assert what what I'm high the
whole thing is magic it's like this is
madness this whole thing is crazy and
there's possibility yes
too many both good and bad possibilities
but they're there that's what I like
that's what people say they pop make
some paranoid I'm like that's my
favorite part
cuz that paranoia I need it it's for
thinking for me it's giant it helps me a
lot
it really does it's it's responsible for
a lot of my activity you know like some
people say that it makes you lazy like
it's not I'm not getting lazy I'm
getting some gay
scared and then because then I go I go I
gotta go kind of do something yeah it
was I remember um Harlan Ellison who was
very anti-drug very anti drink but he
was putting together an anthology he had
LK dick story faith of our fathers in it
it was like I've never advocated the use
of psychedelics or drugs but my God if I
could write on this level maybe I would
totally gobble them because he's
operating on a different level right now
yeah well I think people are scared of
them because for rightly so because
we've all heard stories of people losing
everything lose their mind you know we
were talking yesterday about this this
Oh Pharaoh theater sign that hunter s
Thompson had given this couple on their
wedding anniversary or their with their
wedding day he stole from from San
Francisco he stole his yeah he stole the
sign outside and it was a sign that said
you know if you are scared of sex acts
or whatever it's on there's a guy I
follow on Instagram the jack understand
underscore elope and he's a hunter s
Thompson enthusiast name posted this the
hunter gave it to this couple along with
twenty hits of acid and the woman took
all the acid and was immediately checked
into a mental institution and never got
out so on the day of their wedding
hunter as Thompson ruined it there's
that there's the photo I don't know if
you could see it you can see you there
yeah oh there you go yeah so but the
story is so quick scroll to the story
Jamie on that's right yeah so you can
see where it said gave it to his friend
along with twenty hits of acid as a
wedding gift the bride took the acid was
committed to a mental institution never
came back by the way look I'm I am very
for people if you want to experiment
with psychedelics but I'm also very for
set the correct stage for it also dope
don't take all twenty you [ __ ] crazy
[ __ ] take one hit what they five one
see what where it goes but also even if
you do one don't do it on the roof of a
building with Tom Petty's free falling
playing on a boombox
baby lion a hammock somewhere first time
I did acid was the night that Bill
Clinton won the presidency this is in 92
and I was in matte wine holds apartment
in San Francisco and that wine told that
his roommate this illustrator named
Derek Robertson Marvel illustrator great
comic book guy did trans metropolitan he
Illustrated Warren Ellis is Franz
metropolitan and the boys for Garth
Ennis they owned every action figure in
the world they and they had them all on
little shows what walls were nothing but
action figures I'm sitting there and you
know the patterns in the table started
to melt to move a little bit and then
that plate would max on don't start
thinking about tomorrow never they were
all dancing to that on stage yes when
they were bores in the clintons I looked
over at the wall and the figures weren't
going crazy but as the music played they
were all just kind of subtly I just kind
of bounced like they were in line
outside of like a soundcheck just
listening music and it it gave me this
thing of such act absolutely like oh
like everything in the world is like
bouncing to a better beat right now it
felt really really good it was perfect
I'm the take Jake out was Dean
[Applause]